my name is Jorden and my question is can
I have several powers Thank You Jordan
Jordan Jordan can you have superpowers
you're asking an excellent question I
think it depends what you mean so for me
as a guy of your age I very much wanted
to be able to fly like Superman but I
tried several experiments I was
completely unable to do so even if I put
on a cape and I look at your video I say
you're wearing a super guy outfit you
and you look super but without a cape I
don't know how well it's going to work
the cape seemed to be key for Superman
but even so you know we had a lot of
stories when I was a kid that so-and-so
thought he had superpowers and he jumped
off the roof and he got killed he jumped
off the roof but he broke his leg and so
don't jump off the roof you probably
don't have superpowers but then when you
think about the Justice League of
America think about Superman Aquaman
Wonder Woman and in there is Batman now
Batman didn't have super doesn't have
super powers he's a human yep he made it
into the Justice League as a superhero
because he was so smart he took care of
himself is quite a gymnast quite an
athlete and he made all these cool
devices the bat boomerang the Batarang
the utility belt which was for always
super clever bat stuff so I believe I
believe that Batman was as close to
you're going to get to having
superpowers really smart trained himself
athletically really good athlete too he
was a complete he is a complete guy as
humans go so strive for that and if you
can find a way to fly for real just
jumping off your feet and fly
Laing without jumping off the roof you
know let us know I've met by the way
I've met a Swiss skydiver
who kind of is the guy who developed the
wingsuit he jumps out of planes just
wearing a wing like wearing a cape like
Batman has or Superman has and he's had
some success but a lot of people that
have tried that have had they haven't
had success so careful another guy I
always admire is spider-man you know he
can almost fly using technology that is
to say Peter Parker was so clever he
developed his web fluid that allowed him
to squirt it on to build it flip it flip
onto buildings and then swing between
them amazing almost flying and the other
thing he has that I all I think we all
wish we had is his spider sense
he says his spider sense is tingling
when he senses danger and I submit to
you Jordan that we all have kind of a
spider sense that we all have a sense of
when someone else is not being honest
with us we all have a sense when someone
else is being honest with us and it's
facial expressions it's the way they
stand the way their voice changes or
doesn't change gives you a sense of
whether or not you can trust that person
and that is a I think we all want that
in spades that is to say we all want
that spider sense it turned up as high
as it'll go and I think you can develop
that spider sense when you interact with
people think about what they're really
telling you think about what's what's
really true and find people you trust
and embrace that or give them a hug take
care of yourself
do well in school and if you can pursue
physical athleticism gymnastics
wrestling I recommend bicycling and
carry on Jordan you can do this man
and this one last thing I mean do what
you you handle it your way but I think
you should have a cape I think you
should have a cape
you